Michael you and I got to check out
battle mode and doom eternal which is
actually pretty cool at least from what
we saw we played I don't know we played
a couple hours of it we checked out two
different maps and got to play all the
demons but what's the gist of it
gist of it is that it's a asymmetrical
multiplayer mode where one player is
doom Slayer with all the weapons and
abilities that you get from a single
player and a team of two on the other
side who can play as the demons and the
demons kind of play as different classes
because they have different abilities
they have different attacks ways of
moving around the map and I think it's
it has a lot more depth than I think
what you might see through in the
gameplay because once you get hands-on
with it you realize just how much is
going on
with battle mode and to talk about what
Doom Slayer brings for battle mode is
that it essentially has a recreation of
what the single-player is like because
you're using all those same abilities
because the demon team is spawning in
minions that are demons so you're going
through the same motions which is very
exciting because that is the best part
of the single-player game is getting in
those combat arenas using your chainsaw
using glory kills using the flame belt
you get armor back and all those things
to keep yourself alive as these two
demons are pounding you so it yeah the
way it's software has translated the
best parts of the single-player game
into the multiplayer if you play as Doom
Slayer it is it's impressive I think it
is so then what is the objective of
these rounds so is it just for the doom
Slayer to basically clear the map or do
you have to you have to kill the other
players yes good question so when if
you're playing as Doom Slayer you have
to kill the two player controlled demons
within a certain time frame though
because they respawn after like what was
it 30 seconds so some think it's about
20 seconds ish and you kind of have to
think about your the way you attack the
player control demons because if you
kill one
you put yourself on a sort of countdown
I need to get to the next demon before
the other one can respawn so it kind of
pushes you to be aggressive constantly
and what's the other demon spawns back
in they'll have like half health about
so it'll make it a little bit easier for
doom slayer it's not like you reset back
back to square one if you can't get to
the other demon in time but it still
puts a lot of pressure on you and that's
how you win rounds as doom Slayer
as demons you just need a kill doom
Slayer period and that sounds simple but
it's actually kind of complicated
because of how do player can keep
themselves alive with glory kills and
chainsaw kills so you might think that
you have dupe Slayer corner like you
know we're gonna win the round because
he's down to the 10th help this has
happened to me as doom Slayer I was down
to ten health I hit a chainsaw kill on
one of the minions got my ammo back got
armor and health back and then I came
back to win the round because then I
just turned it around it's like a game
of tug-of-war
but these rounds can go on for a very
long time they can very quickly there's
no time limit because at least what the
developers are saying is they really
like that back and forth that tug him
pulled between the doom Slayer and
demons and they were saying that people
in the office they would those games
would last 10 20 minutes or so if you've
got a really good doom Slayer and two
demons that are super well coordinated
speaking of demons though what were some
of the demons you got to play wow you
have we had five different demons that
we could get hands on with during the
demo time and there will be more in the
future but for now we have hands-on with
the man Kubis which is kind of a
slow-moving tank if you've seen him in
the single-player load that it has to
funk and throwers yeah yeah very like
just a tank that can take on a lot of
damage but also do a lot of damage
of course you're limited in terms of
mobility you also play as a CAC a demon
and fly across the map and it feels kind
of good to be able to have that freedom
to fly around on the map it's also
creates a different kind of strategic
aspect because in one of the maps when I
was on when I was playing doom Slayer
the CagA demon would fly as high as
possible and just like try and pick me
off and distract me while the other
demons
would come and attack me so I really
have to think about what all these
demons bring to the table because you
can coordinate in that fashion and my
favorite was the Marauder because you
can throw an axe on one hand and you
have a double-barrel shotgun on the
other so it's a really good aggressive
style of demon and I think that plays
closest to how dudes doom Slayer is so
you can do some really tricky things and
there's also revenant which has I think
like rocket launchers and stuff and some
other abilities some cool movement and
like jetpack so you can move around the
map more cleverly yeah there's there's
just a lot going on with the different
demons so we get a lot of time with
battle mode though and I think one of
the concerns especially if you're a
newer player or if you haven't played
through the single-player
I think balance might be all over the
place I mean especially like if you
haven't finished the single-player you
don't know what half these guns do and
you're going up against demons they
could crush you pretty quickly or the
opposite if you're fighting against
demons who just started and you're a
pretty good doom Slayer like you're
gonna know exactly which weapons you
need for each situation and you could
potentially clear them out pretty
quickly yeah I do have a bit of
hesitation when it comes to how
matchmaking is gonna play out because if
you if you're playing demons and you
have another player who isn't really
coordinating with you it can I could see
it falling apart rather quickly so you'd
want to have players on both sides who
kind of know what they're doing and
that's gonna be hard to find I'm sure
that the game will eventually find its
footing after release but I can see the
ways in which balance would be an issue
now talking to Marty strand Google
Martin internally they've had a lot of
testing with balance and all that stuff
but because they're putting a lot of
resources into this and they've gotten
to a point where internally there are
about 50/50 with that but of course
things shake out differently when it
actually goes public and people start to
dip their toes into the multiplayer mode
and I think you know we'll see updates
and tweaks to how that's going to work
but in terms of playing at a high level
it's a very exciting kind of take on it
whether you would like it or not it's
nice to see that do
internals trying something drastically
different from the standard multiplayer
modes that we saw into 2016 yeah I mean
I think that's one of the most exciting
things right is that at least they're
not trying that doom 2016 multiplayer
they're trying something different
hopefully it works out but only time
will tell
doom eternal comes out March 20th and
for more stay tuned the game spot
[Music]